GAS.
NOW, WE HAVE A BIG PROBLEM IN
THIS COUNTRY.
LET ME GET TO OUR FIRST GUEST.
PROFESSOR, YOU AND I HAVE A
COMMON BOND, A LOVE OF ISRAEL.
AND WHAT HAS NOW COME OUT ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS SHOULD
OUTRAGE EVERY AMERICAN.
AND THE FACT THAT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY COULD NOT TAKE A STAND AND
NAME THIS WOMAN AND CONDEMN THIS
AND KEEP HER ON THE COMMITTEE TO
ME IS OUTRAGEOUS.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
AND I THINK THESE DEMOCRATS, THE
ONES ON THE EXTREME LEFT ARE
TRYING TO TURN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
CORBIN MAKES THE SAME ARGUMENT.
BUT WHAT OMAR SAID IS CLEARLY
ANTI-SEMETIC.
SHE SHOULD HAVE BEEN CONDEMNED
BY NAME, SINGLED OUT.
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN ISOLATED AS
THE REAL PROBLEM WE'RE
CONFRONTING NOT ONLY IN THIS
COUNTRY BUT AROUND THE WORLD.
BY WATERING IT DOWN, IT WAS AS
IF AFTER THE BLACK CHILDREN WERE
KILLED IN ALABAMA BACK IN THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT AND
SOMEBODY WANTED TO INTRODUCE A
RESOLUTION, SOME SOUTHERNERS
SAID, BUT LET'S ALSO INCLUDE
ATTACKS ON WHITE CHILDREN.
THAT'S NOT THE WAY YOU DO IT.
YOU LOOK AT THE PROBLEM.
THE PROBLEM IS ANTI-SEMITISM
COMING FROM OMAR AND OTHERS LIKE
HER, AND THAT HAS TO BE
CONDEMNED AND IT HAS TO BE
CONDEMNED UNIQUELY AND
SINGULARLY AND STRONGLY.
>> Sean: I'M WORRIED ABOUT THE
RISE OF ANTI-SEMITISM IN EUROPE,
THESE INSANE NEW WHITE
SUPREMACISTS GROUPS.
I DON'T CARE WHERE IT COMES
FROM.
IT NEEDS TO BE CONFRONTED AND
STOPPED AND CALLED OUT.
AND I THOUGHT THIS WAS AN ACT OF
COWARDICE THIS WEEK.
>> DEMOCRATS AND OTHERS AND
PEOPLE ON THE THE LEFT WON'T
CONDEMN BLACK LIVES MATTER.
BLACK LIVES MATTER IN THEIR
PLATFORM.
CALLS IT APARTHEID.
I WILL NOT SUPPORT THE
ORGANIZATION BLACK LIVES MATTER
BECAUSE I HAVE ZERO TOLERANCE
FOR ANTI-SEMITISM, FOR
ANTI-CATHOLICISM.
>> Sean: I'VE GOT TO MOVE ON,
THOUGH.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT ADAM SCHIFF
AND, PROFESSOR, THIS ONE BIT OF
TESTIMONY OF BRUCE OHR IS
SHOWING MANY LIV
SHOWING MANY LIES AND
CONTRADICTIONS.
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE THE FISA
WARRANTS, THE 302'S, THE GANG OF
EIGHT INFORMATION, AND WE'RE
GOING TO GET ALL THE TESTIMONY
OF ALL OF THESE PEOPLE.
AND WHAT WE'RE LEARNING IS --
>> WE SHOULD SEE EVERYTHING,
MM-HM.
>> Sean: OKAY.
BUT WHAT BOTHERS ME --
>> TRANSPARENCY IS THE ESSENCE,
YEAH.
>> Sean: WE NOW KNOW MANY PEOPLE
LIED UNDER OATH.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF THAT TAPE
WITH HIM THINKING HE'S TALKING
TO A RUSSIAN?
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF HIS STAFF
SPENDING TEN HOURS WITH MICHAEL
COHN?
>> WELL, WE NOW KNOW THAT THE
ALLEGATIONS IN THE STEELE
DOSSIER AREN'T EVEN SUPPORTED BY
STEELE.
I THINK THAT FISA COURT OUGHT TO
CONSIDER HOLDING IN CONTEMPT OF
COURT PEOPLE WHO SUBMITTED THE
FISA APPLICATION WHILE
WITHHOLDING RELEVANT INFORMATION
THAT MIGHT HAVE LED THEM TO A
DIFFERENT CONCLUSION.
LOOK, WE LIVE IN SUCH A STRANGE
TIME.
THE OTHER HEADLINE IS JUSSIE
SMOLLETT'SING GETTING INDICTED.
THANKFULLY, IT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
ANYBODY WHO FALSELY ACCUSES
ANYBODY SHOULD BE CALLED TO
TASK.
I'VE BEEN FALSELY ACCUSED.
FORTUNATELY, I WAS ABLE TO --
NOBODY SHOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE
FALSE ACCUSATIONS AND GET AWAY
WITH IT.
>> Sean: I'VE LIVED WITH THAT MY
WHOLE CAREER, AND THE STANDARD
IS SO HIGH, EVEN YOU AND AN ARMY
COULDN'T WIN A CASE.
I AM GLAD ABOUT THESE COVINGTON
KIDS THAT HAVE A GREAT LAWYER
AND WHAT HAPPENED IN HIS CASE
WAS A DISGRACE.
ALL RIGHT.
I WANT TO REMIND EVERYBODY, YOU
ARE GOING TO WRITE AN
INTRODUCTORY RESPONSE TO THE
MUELLER REPORT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Sean: AND THAT WILL BE COMING
OUT --
>> JUST DAYS AFTER THE MUELLER
REPORT BECOMES PUBLIC.
I'M WORKING WITH A VERY, VERY